The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: We turn
today to Alfred Hitchcock,
one of the most
remarkable, if not
the most remarkable
and significant,
of what we might call the
great studio directors,
the people who worked
with great ease
and success inside
the studio system
that developed in
the United States--
began to develop in
the United States
in more than embryonic form,
in early systematic form
in the silent era and then
was fortified and extended
into the great
mass manufacturing
center for dreams and
movies, the Hollywood
system of the studio era.
And I wanted to begin by
saying a word about Hitchcock
in relation to
that great system.
If we think about a famous
quotation from the great film
scholar, pioneering
film critic Andre Bazin,
to whom we will return
later in the semester.
Bazin, among his other
an influential comments,
this one is a particularly
powerful and significant one.
"The American cinema," he wrote
in 1957, "is a classical art,"
and it's unclear exactly
what he meant by that,
but most critics assume
that what he meant by
that is that it's a system that
works according to essentially
classical genre forms, that
these genre forms have origins
behind the movies, and
that the system works
in a kind of a generic
way, and that at least
that's a part of
what he meant when
he called it a classical art.
The American cinema
is a classical art,
but why not then admire it
in what is most admirable,
not only the talent of
this or that filmmaker,
but the genius of the system.
And I think I alluded
to this phrase
or used this phrase
earlier in the term,
and I want to do justice
to it by acknowledging
its origins in Andre Bazin.
There's also a wonderful book by
a film scholar from Texas named
Tom Schatz called The
Genius of the System,
and it borrows, it uses this
quotation as its inspiration,
and it's a systematic analysis
of the Hollywood studio
system in which it talks
about the interaction
of individual
agency-- the writers,
the directors,
the camera people,
and so forth, the
customers-- the interaction
of those creative or
semi-creative figures
with the manufacturing
and publicity practices
and rituals that surrounded
the production of movies
in which he tries to provide a
kind of integrated sense of how
the system worked to explore
what Bazin apparently
meant when he talked about
the genius of the system.
Well, one way of understanding
the genius of the system
is to recognize that it creates
an environment, first of all,
of stability in which
particular filmmakers
or particular
writers or directors
can have confidence-- sometimes
overwhelming confidence
because they're ordered to do
the job by the studio head--
can have confidence that the
genre stories they're creating
have an audience.
And of course, that's
been sort of established
by the, essentially, assembly
line system that develops,
and the elaborate system
of distribution and access
that developed in
the United States.
The major studios actually,
although they only
controlled something like
16% of the resources they--
of movie-making--
actually controlled
a much larger percentage
of the theaters,
because many of the theaters
either were owned outright
by studios or until a certain
point when a Supreme Court
decision divested
the studios from--
forced the studios
to divest themselves
from their theatrical holdings.
But when the system
was in place,
it was a monopoly system in
which the rich got richer,
in some sense, and the
major studios controlled,
owned many theaters
themselves and by a system
of what was called
block booking,
they forced theaters not
just to book particular films
and particular stars
that they might like,
but MGM would say to
independent theater owners,
if you want the MGM films, you
have to take my whole card.
You can't just choose
the Clark Gable movies,
you have to choose
the whole thing.
And this stability
created an environment
in which each major studio
was confident that, in effect,
it had a captive
market for its product,
and it created an immense sense
of stability and confidence
when the system was
working at its best.
And of course,
again, because it was
a system that was committed
to entertaining the largest
number of people it
could reach as possible,
it meant that there were
certain parameters that
were established within which
the entire system was forced
operate.
Whatever genre was
involved, there
were certain kinds of limits.
It's what I was talking
about earlier, trying
to get at this aspect
of the system earlier,
when I talked about the
idea of consensus narrative.
If the Hollywood
film is reaching out
to the whole of the
society and it's telling,
essentially, a story that
appeals to or is supposed
to embody the consensus view,
the largest general view
of what the belief system of
the society is, what that means
is that there are limits,
very sharp constraints--
political and moral
constraints-- within which
the text operates.
And as you know, especially
if you've been reading your
[? Cook, ?] the introduction
of a particular sensory system
introduced by Hollywood
itself in order
to avoid other
kinds of censorship
perhaps from the
government, further
constrained the kinds of
stories that could be told.
Well, within those
constraints, of course,
as I hope I've already
begun to show you
in our discussion
of screwball comedy,
there can be an immense
range of difference,
but it's still within certain
controlled parameters.
And one of the
ways to understand
Hitchcock's immense
success is to recognize
that he had the kind of
sensibility, the kind
of artistic impulses,
and maybe even
the kinds of limitations that
made the studio system a kind
of perfect environment for him.
Anyone who's looked at a
Hitchcock-- more than one
or two Hitchcock films,
is aware of the fact
that there's
something obsessional,
something deeply disturbing
about Hitchcock's imagination.
He's drawn again,
and again, and again
to the same kinds of situations,
to scenes of violence
against women, to
scenes of confinement,
but the studio system was a
kind of perfect environment
for these kinds
of preoccupations.
On the one hand, the
constraints of the system
did not allow Hitchcock,
even if he had the impulse
to do so, to press so
far into the perversity
and disturbance that is the
general subject matter he is
looking at, as to actually
fall into, say, pornography
or to fall into something
that will deeply offend
some segment of the population.
We can see that
these were impulses
in Hitchcock's
imagination though,
because after the-- Hitchcock
lasted long enough, lived
for such a long time-- he
was a successful director
in the silent era.
Then he worked in Britain
during the sound era
and was the most well
known and successful
of all British directors
in the early sound era.
Then in 1940, he came to
the United States for what
as most people recognize
as his American phase.
He emigrated to
the United States
and that's a separate kind of
distinct part of his career,
as I'll describe in a little
more detail in a moment.
Well, by the end of
his career, Hollywood
itself was undergoing
profound changes for reasons
we've already begun to talk
about in this course, the most
important of them being
the advent of television
and the way in which,
through the 1950s,
television began to
leech away the consensus
audience and the consensus
function that Hollywood
had played in American life.
And the effect this was to, in
some sense, liberate Hollywood,
and we'll be talking about what
this ambiguous liberation later
in the course when we look at
some of the great films that
emerge in the 1970s that
are free of the constraints
of a consensus system.
Films like McCabe & Mrs. Miller
or Cabaret, the two films
that we're going to
be looking at later
that embody these sort
of post studio era ideals
and principles.
Well, one of the ways in which
you can see the damage that
was-- the help that was given
to Hitchcock's own imagination
by what I'm calling the
genius of the system,
is that you can see that
Hitchcock's-- that the latest
films that Hitchcock makes,
the films that Hitchcock makes
at the very end of his career,
and especially a film--
two films, a film called Frenzy
starring Michael Caine in 1972,
and the last film the Hitchcock
made in 1976 called Family
Plot.
The same basic
materials, but there's
something gratuitous about
the nudity in these films.
He wasn't allowed to show
nudity in the studio era,
and it was good for
his imagination.
And when his
imagination-- and any
honorable-- any honest viewer
of Hitchcock watching Frenzy,
or especially Family
Plot, and watch--
there's a scene
in Frenzy in which
a murderer strangles a woman.
Now, there have been--
strangulation is
one of Hitchcock's
favorite forms of murder,
and there've been many
characters strangled
in Hitchcock's movie,
but this strangulation
has a pornographic
dimension to it
that none of the early
scenes like that did.
And it has to do with
the fact Hitchcock is now
working in a film environment
that is not telling him
that he can't go too far,
and he does go too far.
And there's a terrible scene
in which a murderer takes off
his tie, and he strangles
this woman with a tie.
The woman is naked
from the waist up,
and you see her breasts
bobbling around on the screen
while she's being
strangled, and you
can see that the
camera is enjoying
looking at those breasts, even
though it's a scene of murder.
It's a very, very horrible
scene, a very disturbing scene.
It's a scene that-- it
almost is a scene that
makes you believe in censorship,
to think that censorship ought
to be-- certainly, you
wouldn't want young people
to see this scene.
Now, the only reason
that Hitchcock
was free to create this scene
is that there were no longer
the same constraints
being imposed
upon him by what I want
to call the constraining
genius of the system.
So my point is
that Hitchcock was
a man of obsessional
genius of a certain sort,
but he had the
great good fortune
to work within a system
that also limited
his liabilities,
that didn't even
allow the full expression
of his obsessions
in ways that might become
deeply disturbing to audiences.
The fact of the matter is,
when you look at that scene
and then you think back at
many earlier Hitchcock movies,
you can see many
equivalents of it.
Violence and damage to women
is a recurring obsession
in Hitchcock.
Hitchcock is a sick
man in many ways.
But he's not a sick
artist, he's a sick person.
He turns his sickness into art.
He turns his sickness into use
by dramatizing it and reminding
us of the-- so insofar as
he's a good filmmaker, he's
not a-- he's not a
horrible perv, right?
But there are perverted
dimensions to Hitchcock.
And in fact, part of why
we find him interesting
is his films are always hovering
on the brink of awakening
in us feelings that are
disturbing and unsettling,
and that touch on deep
taboos in the ways
in which our culture sort
of understands how we should
behave, and especially in our
attitudes towards sexuality,
and towards seeing,
toward the act of seeing,
which in Hitchcock becomes
a kind of voyeurism.
So one way to
understand Hitchcock
is to understand his genius,
his greatness as a director
as being directly
connected to the fact
that for the most
part of his career,
he worked in systems
that constrained him.
He worked in systems that had
a very sharp boundaries, that
didn't allow him to do
certain kinds of things,
and those limitations
were turned
into artful and
valuable gestures.
An anecdote that Hitchcock
told about himself many times,
this deeply revealing anecdote.
It may not be true.
We're not really sure, but
he told it so many times
that it's true even
if it didn't happen.
That's a line-- it's true
even if it didn't happen--
it's a line from Ken
Kesey's wonderful novel,
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest.
And the character, the
narrator in the book, who
was sort of a crazy
man, or we think,
he's in an insane asylum,
he's in a loony bin
when he starts
narrating the story,
tells us a story
of his confinement
in a lunatic
asylum, and he says,
you think the man who's saying
this is raving and crazing?
My god, this is true
even if it didn't happen.
And what he means is there's
a kind of emotional truth,
even if the actual
facts aren't true.
And I think that's true of the
Hitchcock anecdote as well,
and this is the anecdote he
repeatedly told about himself.
He said, when he was a young
boy, five or six years-old,
he committed some indiscretion
that his father disapproved of,
and his father, in response,
without saying anything
to the boy, wrote a note,
sealed it in an envelope,
gave it to the boy, and
told him to take it down
to the local constable--
the policeman
in the police station
around the corner
from where they lived in London.
So the young boy dutifully
took the note to him,
and then gave it
to the constable,
and the constable opened it,
read it, and locked the boy
in a prison cell,
and kept him in there
for a certain short
amount of time,
and then finally
released him, and said,
this is what
happens to bad boys.
And Hitchcock has said,
ever since then, I
have gone to any
length to avoid arrest
and to avoid confinement
in confining spaces.
And in fact, if you think
about it for a second,
over and over again
in Hitchcock's films,
a basic story, not
the only story,
but a basic story he tells
is the story of someone
who is wrongly accused.
We might call it the
wrong man theme, right?
And someone who
was on the run, who
looked at the
circumstantial evidence
against him is-- or her, usually
him-- is overwhelming, right?
Absolutely looks it.
And all the authorities, all
the legitimate authorities
of the culture, think the
protagonist of the Hitchcock
chase film is guilty, right?
And his obligation is to
somehow not only escape
the authorities, who are
much more powerful than he,
of course, and have
at their fingertips
all kinds of modern systems
for searching, and following,
and capturing people,
and the fugitive
is a lone fugitive on
his own without resources
and without allies.
So he's up against
tremendously difficult forces
and these are the forces
of legitimate authority.
So the theme of the wrong
man, who's wrongly accused.
The audience knows that
he's wrongly accused.
Often, Hitchcock will
show the real murderer
and will show us how
circumstantially persuasive
but also falsely evidence is,
so through most of the movie,
we identify with the fugitive,
with the person who's running.
We know he is innocent.
So part of it is--
so many of his films
then sort of dramatize a kind of
massive principle of injustice
that happens again and
again in his movies.
Authorities are almost
always after the wrong man.
And then many of his films,
an overwhelmingly disturbing
recurring element in his films,
is confinement in tight spaces,
is the sense of being caught.
And you'll see one of the
great, great instances of this,
one of his most artistic
accountings of this impulse,
this fear of confinement,
but this fascination
with confinement,
in the great film
you're going to see tonight,
Rear Window, which takes place
entirely in a single
confined space, in a room,
because the man who--
the protagonist has
a broken leg at the
beginning of the film
and he's literally unable to
move out of his apartment.
So the entire film is confined
there, and, of course,
many of Hitchcock's
films love this.
So what an interesting
anecdote to be told.
And think, by
implication, what it
says about his
father, not to mention
what it says about
Hitchcock himself
to tell a story like this
so many times over the whole
of his career.
But the idea that a world
that seems perfectly
benign and protective
could suddenly
turn menacing and terrible, that
behind any door or window lurks
some monstrosity, that
the ordinary world is just
an illusion, that what you
think of as ordinary, and plain,
and prosaic can suddenly erupt
in violence, or in terror,
or in some form of
unpredictable assault
is a constant feeling you
have in Hitchcock's films.
His films dance along an edge in
which the whole of the universe
could be said to be, in
some sense, endangered.
The basic laws of our
experience, of even sometimes
the physical laws
of our experience
are upended, or denied, or
suspended in Hitchcock's world.
Can you think of one example
where the laws of nature
itself suddenly go cuckoo?
One of his most famous films.
AUDIENCE: The Birds.
DAVID THORBURN: The
Birds, of course,
the late film The Birds.
What happens in The Birds?
AUDIENCE: All the birds
start attacking [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID THORBURN: Yes, the most
benign and beautiful parts
of nature suddenly began
to attack human beings.
He gives some partial
explanation in the film,
where you see there's a scene
in a restaurant where you see
pictures of fried
chicken, and people
talking about how they love
roast pheasant, and so forth.
But in all of
Hitchcock's films, there
is never an adequate,
a truly adequate motive
for the madness,
terror, disorder
that is released in the movies.
There's often an
attempt to explain them,
but nobody takes the
explanations very seriously,
because the point is,
his vision of life
is a vision in which the
world is an incredibly
dangerous, wholly unpredictable,
monstrously fearsome place.
Maybe his dominant emotion
is the emotion of fear.
He dramatizes fear over and over
and over again in his movies.
Here is a brief selection.
He made over 50
films, and I think
53 total films, silent and
sound films in his career.
The list I put up there is
just a very brief selection,
but let me say a few
things about the trajectory
of that career and then
I'll turn to a bit more
about his technical genius
and about the central themes
of his work, which I've
already begun to elaborate
and won't repeat myself
too much, I hope.
But let's talk a bit
about his career,
because like Howard
Hawks and Frank Capra,
Hitchcock is, even
more than those two,
a dominant figure of the studio
era, maybe the dominant figure.
Certainly, the director whose
work has been most influential,
has lasted the longest.
One of the most
interesting things
about Hitchcock's
career, as a whole,
is that even after film
came to be recognized
as something more than
mere entertainment,
Hitchcock was always admired
as a great entertainer
and was a successful
director from the silent era
from the time he began
to work in Great Britain.
When he made his move to
the United States in 1939,
he was Britain's most famous
and most admired director.
In fact, when he came
to the United States,
there was a kind of
negative reaction
in Britain, because they
felt it was unpatriotic
of this great director to
desert his native homeland
in the middle of the
war, among other things.
And he did feel guilt
over this, in many ways,
and some of that guilt is
said, by some scholars,
to express itself in some
aspects of the other film
you're going to see this
evening, an earlier film,
made in 1943 shortly
after Hitchcock
had come to the United States.
It wasn't his first
American film.
While he was making
that film, he
was receiving news from
England about his mother, who
was very ill, and
she actually died
while he was in the
United States filming
Shadow of a Doubt.
And there are some
scholars who say
that his familial feelings,
his guilt over leaving England,
his guilt about
deserting his mother
come out in various ways
in Shadow of a Doubt.
I'm not so sure about
that, because it's
a pretty cynical,
and tough-minded,
and anti-sentimental
film in its own way,
but there are some elements
of family life in it
that perhaps recover
or allude to aspects
of Hitchcock's own career.
One significant thing, as
I've already suggested,
is that he was successful at
every phase in the history
of movies that, like
Hawks and Capra,
he began in the silent era, did
distinguished work there, moved
into the sound era and
did distinguished work
in the sound era.
He has something else in
common with Hawks and Capra,
and I only recently
discovered this.
It's not as systematic as in
the case of Hawks and Capra,
but he, too,
studied engineering.
So there must be
something in this.
You guys should
maybe reconsider what
you're up to here,
because three of the most
remarkable and technically
adept directors
in the history of the
studio era all had
partial training as engineers.
So he begins in the silent
era, and in fact, let's
go behind-- let me
say just a little bit
about his background.
He was an outsider,
in a certain way,
even though he
was an Englishman,
because he was a Jesuit.
His parents were Catholic
in Protestant England.
And he felt himself, all his
life, I think in some ways,
to be a kind of outsider,
someone who didn't exactly
fit in traditional society.
He went to work after his
schooling in the advertising
department of a
telegraph company,
began to write the title
cards for silent films
as early as 1921, and then began
for this telegraph company,
began to work on certain
feature films that
were co-produced in Germany.
And this is, of course,
the great period
of German Expressionism,
when the great German silent
directors are creating
their science fiction
and Expressionist works.
And Hitchcock, in
his early life,
is immersed in that
stuff, learns that stuff,
goes to school in that, and
you can feel the Expressionist
impulse in the darkness
and the disturbance that's
a central part of almost
every Hitchcock film.
He makes something like,
I think, a total of six
or seven silent
films of which the--
do we have the list up there,
yes-- of which the most
important is-- The
Pleasure Gardens
was a co-production,
the first film
that he worked on
systematically,
and it was a German
co-production.
He wasn't the prime
director in it.
The Lodger is
probably his most--
almost surely his most
important and most Hitchcockian
silent film.
Can you guess the topic?
It's Jack the Ripper.
It's a silent film.
It's a story about a landlady
who thinks fearfully,
nervously that she may
have rented a room to Jack
the Ripper, the famous killer.
So he's a successful
silent director already,
an admired director, makes
the transition to sound,
and in fact-- historically
he'd be famous
just for this one fact--
Blackmail, a British film he
made in 1929, is the
first British talkie.
And he almost immediately
began to figure out
how to integrate-- was
very interested in all
the technical aspects
of movie-making,
especially interested in the way
you integrate sound with image.
And as anyone who's watched
the shower scene in Psycho,
for example, would
be a famous example,
anyone who's watch these
scenes like that in Hitchcock
will recognize the tremendous
importance of music
in his films.
The way he uses music to
deepen and complicate the moods
he's creating, and especially
how he can use music
to enhance your sense
of terror and fear
as he does in certain frenzied,
powerful scenes in his most
remarkable films.
And then he goes on to really
an immensely successful career
as the director of action
adventure mystery films
of which I've listed the most
famous and significant ones,
films that are still interesting
to people, that are still
watched today for their
own intrinsic excitement,
even though many of them
also feel a bit old-fashioned
in their behavior.
The Man Who Knew Too Much,
The 39 Steps, and The Lady
Vanishes, and there are other
films he made in this era,
I'm only listing a
selection, as I've said.
Then he makes the transition
to the United States.
He's lured here
by David Selznick,
the head of a great studio.
Hitchcock is especially drawn
to coming to the United States
because he envies the
technical resources that
are available to American
directors, who, because they
have much more budget, they
can do much more when they have
enough money to add cameras, and
to have adequate crews, and so
forth.
And the first film he
makes in the United States,
Rebecca, a remake
of a famous novel,
won an Academy Award as
best film of the year,
although Hitchcock did not
win a director's award.
But it's the least Hitchcockian
of all of his films,
and perhaps he was
restraining himself
a little bit in an attempt
to establish himself
in the American audience.
It's a very interesting
film, and you can still
see that it, in some
broad way, fits Hitchcock.
It's a Gothic story, the
classic English novels
about governesses who
go off in the country
to strange mansions, and
they are both attracted to
and repelled by the handsome,
sometimes scarred stranger
who runs the place, right?
I'm talking especially
about what novel?
Jane Eyre, Charlotte
Bronte's great novel.
And of course, that pattern--
that [INAUDIBLE] that pattern
repeats itself again
and again in the movies,
and Rebecca is a version
of that kind of story.
And then Hitchcock
goes on in the '40s
to make a series of films
in which his own interest
in the technology
of motion pictures
and his own obsession
with setting problems
for himself that are
difficult to solve,
his own sort of engineer's
obsession with the technology
of motion picture begins to
become clearer and clearer.
Another reason that The Lodger
is an important Hitchcock film
is that it's the first film in
which Hitchcock himself makes
a brief cameo
appearance, and after
that it becomes a kind of
signature feature of his movies
that at some point in
the film, a character--
Alfred Hitchcock
will appear briefly.
He won't be identified, he
won't be noticed in the credits,
but as he became more
and more well known,
audiences began
to watch for this.
This bothered him in
some way, because it
meant that it distracted people
from the movies themselves,
because they were waiting to
see when Hitch would emerge,
so he began to do it earlier
and earlier in the films
in order to avoid
distracting audiences.
But think what it means,
having to devise a way for him
to be in the movie.
In many cases, it's easy.
OK, a man's getting on a bus, so
he can be in the crowd of the--
but what happens when he makes
films that are arbitrarily
restricted, as he
does in some cases?
For example, the film
Lifeboat, in 1944, some of you
know about it.
It takes place
entirely on a lifeboat.
There are eight or
nine characters.
They've escaped a shipwreck.
It's a World War II
parable about Nazism,
and they're all stuck
in the lifeboat.
And for the entire
film, the film
is confined to that lifeboat.
It presents all kind-- it's
not one of his best films,
but the technical
challenge presented
is really interesting, isn't it?
Vertigo was an even more
interesting instance,
and a much more
successful instance
of the same desire or
the same weird impulse
in Hitchcock himself to
create confining situations
and then see what that
confinement allows him to do,
what grows out of these
arbitrary limitation.
But just as a kind of minor
instance of this kind of thing,
if all the characters
in Lifeboat
are on a boat in the
middle of the ocean,
how can Hitchcock appear?
Because he's not one
of the main characters.
Does anyone know how he did it?
There's a newspaper lying
on the floor of the boat,
and you pick up the newspaper,
and there's a picture
of Hitchcock in the newspaper.
It's a trivial thing,
but it [INAUDIBLE],
but its triviality is exactly
what makes it so interesting.
In other words, what Hitchcock
loved, this kind of problem.
When he took these
problems in a serious way
and when these problems
sort of led him
into a kind of exploration of
our darker, and more disturbed,
and more uncivilized sides,
he made remarkable films that
are memorable and haunting.
And one more
example of Hitchcock
setting himself these
difficult technical feats.
The film Rope, well
titled in a way.
It's a murder mystery, but
Hitchcock set it up in a way,
it's actually, such that,
it creates the illusion
that the entire film-- I
don't remember how long it is.
Let's say it's a standard
feature length film.
Let's say it's 89 minutes long.
It's a standard
feature length film.
It feels as if it's all
unraveled in a single take,
as if there are no cuts,
no edits in the movie.
Now, it's not exactly true,
because the film was not
capable, technically,
of doing that.
What Hitchcock did was, he
had cassettes of film that
would last, say, 10 minutes.
So he would make 10-minute
long takes, but then he'd
have to change the
cassette, put in a new one,
but he disguised the takes.
He disguised the cuts.
And in fact, it's an
unbelievably tedious film,
because when you're watching it,
you feel you can't look away.
One of the things
that you discover
when you're watching this
film is that cuts are actually
a relaxation.
They let you relax.
They break the
rhythm in some way.
And if you sit there for 89
minutes watching something that
seems to be unfolding--
and film, of course,
unfolds in real time,
also, therefore, right?
So he's playing both
with another kind
of confinement, which is
the duration of the movie.
He's saying, I'm going to make
the duration of the viewing
the same duration as
the action of the movie,
and I'm never going
to cut, or I'm
going to create the illusion
that there's not going
to be a single edit in my film.
When you're watching
it, you actually,
yourself, feel trapped.
You feel guilty if
you look away, or you,
but you constantly want
to blink or look down,
because it's almost as
if the absence of edits
creates a kind of continuous
stream of imagery,
and you feel you're trapped
within it, like a wall that
doesn't let you escape from it.
Well, that kind
of-- I don't know
that Hitchcock actually
intended such a reaction,
but is not inconsistent
with Hitchcock's desire
to manipulate your feelings
as you're watching a film.
And he became a master at
manipulating your reactions
as you watch the film.
So there are many-- and I
could cite many other examples
of this sort of
technical obsession,
but let me just say a couple of
things about the major films.
And he successfully,
in every phase,
but he really
comes into his own,
most folks critics would
say, at the end of the 1940s
with a series of-- maybe the
early '50s-- with a series
of films that run from
'51 through, maybe,
most people would say
through The Birds in 1963.
And I haven't listed all the
films he made in that era,
but I've listed the
most important ones,
and you can judge for yourself
how significant this is, why?
Because look at how many
titles you recognize.
How many titles by
directors so many years ago
would you actually have seen?
It's one measure of what
an important figure, what
a successful figure Hitchcock
is that he's still so widely
known, that he's more
famous today than he was
when he was making his movies.
As I started to say earlier, one
of the most distinctive things
or interesting and revealing
things about Hitchcock's career
is that through the
mass of his career,
even though he was one of
the most popular directors,
and his films made
money, and he was
a totally bankable
director, no, maybe
the most bankable
director in Hollywood
during the studio era, he
didn't get much respect.
Some people have suggested
that one of the reasons for it
is that he gave so much
pleasure that there
was a feeling that anyone
who gave this much pleasure
couldn't be an artist, that
it worked against him that he
was such a great entertainer.
And there may be
something to that.
But steadily over time, and
especially since his death,
his reputation has increased,
and increased, and increased.
And in fact, recently,
his film Vertigo
was voted the best film
of all time, the best film
ever made, displacing
Orson Welles' Citizen
Kane, which had been at the
top of this list for something
like 20 years.
And this ascension in
which Hitchcock was sort of
denigrated as a mere entertainer
to now being recognized
as one of the greatest
artists in the movies
of the 20th century is a
very interesting development,
and it's a development that's
partly a function of the fact
that all of that happened
after the movies were
no longer the central narrative
experience in the modern world
in which they had already
been displaced as a system.
So in this period
between Strangers
on a Train through
The Birds in 1963--
some people might
include Marnie in '64--
he made a series of
masterpieces that
are among the most
significant and most powerful
films ever made, two of which
we're talking about tonight.
Hitchcock the technician.
I've already implied
something about this,
but it's worth emphasizing this.
Hitchcock became famous,
especially in the industry,
for the unbelievably
fastidious, almost bored way
in which he carried out
his direction of a movie.
By the time Hitchcock got
to the set of the film,
he had so obsessively planned
out every aspect of the movie
that he acted as if
everything was all finished.
He often annoyed his actors.
Some actors disliked
him a lot, because he
gave very little
instruction to his actors,
and some actors like this, but
many resented it a great deal.
See, he's been quoted
a number of times
as showing a kind of
disregard for actors.
At one point, he
said actors are just
cattle to be moved around
on the set like animals.
But it was more of the fact that
the actors had trouble with him
because he seemed to have
worked everything out
before he got to the set.
He was always tremendously calm,
he sat in his director's chair,
would give directions,
and he had storyboarded--
he had drawn out every single
scene and every single camera
angle before he even
came to the set,
so that it was as if he
had worked everything out
before he reached the set.
And what that meant,
of course, is that
no improvisation on the set.
He would be very unhappy
if people tried to deviate,
never allowed people to
deviate from the plans that
had been set before.
This is in shocking contrast
to the way in which, let's say,
a director like Jean Renoir
or sometimes Orson Welles
might operate in
making their films.
Quite the-- looking
for the contingent
and the accidental that
happens while you're
at work creatively.
Hitchcock would
have none of that.
Hitchcock came into the
process of directing
with the film finished,
completed in his head,
completely,
fastidiously blocked,
angled, and so forth, and
there was no deviation from it.
And he actually did often
act bored when he did it.
How interesting that is.
But he's also, of course,
a supreme technician
of the movies, a
master of camera angle,
a master of montage, a master
of the mingling of music
and image, right?
And you'll see
many, many examples
of this in the two films we
are going to see this evening.
How interesting, then, that he
is this incredibly fastidious,
granular technician who plans
out every single camera angle
before he comes on the set.
What does this tell us?
Why would he do that?
What's interesting about it?
What's most revealing about it?
Why would someone do this?
Maybe if the subject matter
you're trying to deal with
is so unruly and so
frightening that the only way
you could handle it
is by surrounding it
with this pretense of fastidious
coherence and control.
And I think that there's
no question at all
that his cool demeanor,
his mocking demeanor,
and especially his sense when
he comes to actually make
the film, that all the
problems have been solved,
that everything has
already been done,
is an attempt to compensate
for or defend himself
against the roiling irrational
power of the subject matter
that his films mobilize.
What a wonderful
revealing paradox, right?
He's this fastidious
technician, but his themes
are the themes of
craziness, of madness,
of murder, of voyeurism,
of violence, of rape,
of strangulation, of fear,
of pursuit, imprisonment,
confinement, injustice.
One the most interesting
things about Hitchcock,
and those of you
who have seen more
than two or three of his
films will feel this much
more strongly than those of you
who've only seen a few of them,
is how essentially passive,
deeply unaggressive,
and acted upon most of
his protagonists are.
They're being pursued.
They're on the run.
They're confined
in small places.
They're full of fear.
One of Hitchcock's recurring
moments, a recurring scene,
is the protagonist
dangling from a height.
And you'll see one
magnificent instance of this
at the end of Rear Window,
where Jimmy Stewart is hanging
like this above a void,
and you see his face,
and you can see his face
register abject fear, right?
We could call that one of
Hitchcock's iconic moments.
It occurs again and again in his
movies, of characters hanging
over a void, terrified,
terrified of what
is about to happen, and often
they fall into the void,
and some of the dream
sequences in Hitchcock
show us characters falling
through voids into nothingness.
So the subject matter
of Hitchcock's films
couldn't be more shocking
and disturbing in some sense.
They mobilize problematic
subjects that are terrifying,
and they obviously were
so terrifying to Hitchcock
that his only way
of dealing with them
was to surround them with all
this appearance of control.
Another thing that
follows from this,
and it's a very--
on a final point
to make about Hitchcock's
films, is how often
his reassuring or
happy endings don't
reassure or make us happy.
And the reason, of
course, is that he
doesn't mean the happy endings.
I'll come back to this again.
But very often, even though his
films fit perfectly within--
or imperfectly, but well
enough-- into the convention
that the endings in
a consensus system,
and the endings of these
stories have to, in some sense,
restore normality
and reassure us,
Hitchcock goes through
the motions of doing that,
but again and again,
the endings of his films
are morally ambiguous,
and provide us
with kind of subtext which put
in question the reassurance
that we have superficially
been offered, as if there's
a level of irony, and cynicism,
and deconstructive contempt
beneath, undermining
the reassurance
that the endings offer us.
And that's also a
part of this idea
that the themes that
Hitchcock mobilizes are
the dark elements
of our subconscious
and of our unconscious, and
the fear that people have, fear
of authority, fear of
disorder, fear of disturbance,
a sense that the ordinary world
is full of menace and terror.
But again and again
in Hitchcock's films,
he doubles his
characters, and you'll
have a good character
and an evil character,
and the idea-- he grew up in
the late Victorian era of Robert
Louis Stevenson, Dr.
Jekyll and Mr. Hyde,
and he actually thought that was
a version of human psychology,
that there's a kind of dark
or savage aspect in ourselves
that's hidden or damped
down by civilization,
and if we let it come out,
we could turn monstrous,
we could turn horrible, right?
And again and again
in Hitchcock's films,
we have a kind of doubling in
which one character interacts
with a more villainous
or murderous character,
who we come to recognize
as a kind of double
of the protagonist,
or represents
the darker, more
disturbing energies
within the protagonist's
nature, right?
And in Strangers on a
Train, what happens,
a tennis star, who's having
trouble with his wife,
is on a train, and a guy
pops up next to him and says,
I know you're having
trouble with your wife.
I read about it
in the newspaper.
Let's make a deal.
Nobody could track us.
It'll be the perfect murder.
I'm having trouble with my wife.
You murder my wife
and I'll murder yours.
Then the guy said, get thee
behind me, Satan, right?
Don't ever talk to me again.
I'm very nervous about it.
A few weeks later, his
wife is murdered, right?
And then he starts getting
messages from this guy,
when are you going to fulfill
your part of the bargain?
That's what the film is about.
And it's a wonderful,
interesting movie.
The scene I want you to see
now dramatizes some of this.
It comes at end of the film, at
the great climax of the film,
and one reason I
want you to see it
is that it also shows
another aspect of his what
we might call the thematic
world of Hitchcock's films,
and it's his recurring interest
in the subject of entertainment
itself.
What he became aware of and
what his films often dramatize
is the illicit and disturbing
dimension of our desire
to go to the movies,
or of our desire
to have the kinds
of excitements we
get when we go to
amusement parks.
What Hitchcock understood
was that these experiences
have an illicit dimension.
We sit in the dark, and what do
we do when we sit in the dark?
We watch people take
their clothes off.
We watch them murder each other.
We're in the dark.
We're safe.
Nobody knows.
We're solitary.
We're anonymous.
But we're, what are we?
We're voyeurs.
And what he understood
was that voyeurism
was at the heart of
going to the movies,
the movie experience,
and that there-- we'll
come back to this.
We'll come back to this scene.
So at the end of
Strangers on a Train,
there's a particularly
wonderful and dramatic example
of Hitchcock looking at
the space of entertainment
as a space that can turn
into an environment of menace
and disturbance.
And this is
character-- and again,
exactly because-- remember,
I said one of his deep themes
is what we might call the
menace of the ordinary.
Well, what could be more
ordinary and reassuring
than a child's merry-go-round?
Well, here's the great
climax of Strangers
on a Train in which the good
and the bad, the good and evil
sides have to engage in a kind
of contest or wrestling match.
And as you're
watching, note the way
in which, characteristic of
Hitchcock, characteristic
of him, there's a combination
of terror and comedy.
He unsettles us, also,
because often the most
terrifying scenes are leavened
with a kind of macabre comedy
that unsettles us even more.
Here's the scene.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MERRY-GO-ROUND MUSIC]
Good guy, bad guy.
He finally sees his double.
These are very
helpful FBI people
who do more harm than good.
They shoot at the wrong
person to begin with,
and they accidentally
shoot the person
who's controlling
the merry-go-round,
so it goes out of control.
-Everyone stand back.
Stand back, please.
-[INAUDIBLE], sir.
That's him.
-He's the one.
He's the one who killed him.
-[INAUDIBLE].
We know that.
DAVID THORBURN: Part of the
comedy here is they're wrong.
They don't know who
they're talking about.
They have the wrong man, but
we in the audience know it.
-Hey, [INAUDIBLE], stop.
-Or do you want
to do it yourself?
-No.
I guess you could
make [INAUDIBLE].
-My little boy [INAUDIBLE].
My little boy.
Please.
DAVID THORBURN: See,
only Hitch-- Hitchcock
had such confidence that he
could introduce a comic moment
like that in the middle of
what is a terrifying climax.
The only director who
would do that regularly.
[LAUGHTER]
Now you know who the
bad guy is, right?
So the hero rescues the kid.
[SCREAMING]
Is this a montage or a
mise en scene effect?
A montage effect, right?
See the close up on
the animal, the way
you get very-- the
camera itself doesn't
allow you to sort
of look back and get
a sense of the environment?
Your emotions are controlled
by the tightness of the shot,
by the quickness of the editing.
Comic version of a hero, right?
And this is
quintessential Hitchcock.
Are we saved?
Very helpful.
All right, that's enough.
You get the idea.
[END PLAYBACK]
And so the fact that this
space of entertainment--
can you get lights up?
The fact that this
space of entertainment
could become a-- one more
minute, people-- could become
a space of terror is the point.
So finally, what would
we say about Hitchcock?
He's a double man.
To borrow from the great
essayist Montaigne, who said,
we human beings are, I know
not how, doubling ourselves,
so that what we
believe, we disbelieve,
and cannot rid ourselves
of what we condemn.
What Hitchcock tries
or condemn or what
Hitchcock thinks he hates
keeps coming back in his films.
Images of strangulation, of
damage to women, images of fear
and terror in the face
of irrational authority.
These themes keep
returning again and again
in his film with the
power of obsession,
but he controls the obsession
with that fastidious technical
distance that allows these
obsessions to reach us
in a way that disturbs
and enlightens.